so why on earth am ia gay affirming
Christian that's the topic I'd like to
unpack today welcome to Table Talk where
each week on pack insights from
Christian theology and spirituality that
help you become more thoughtful calm and
just a downright great human being
my name is Brett silver pastor at the
table at church in Sachse Texas and I'm
very excited to jump into our topic for
today since it's one that honestly it is
deeply personal for me
so in this episode I want to share a bit
of my story and why I care about this
topic so much so for the years 2000
about 2008 through 2012 I went through
there's lots of terms for this dark
night of the soul crisis of faith
deconstruction whatever you want to call
it but it was a time of questioning that
led to some major shifts in my faith
I've been raised in a fairly
conservative Protestant evangelical kind
of context and so for a variety of
intellectual reasons I was released
struggling with that kind of approach to
Christian faith most of my questions in
such centered on the Bible in the usual
suspects I mean I was not amazingly
unique it was you know divine violence
in the Old Testament it was the doctrine
of hell understood as eternal conscious
torment a relationship to science that
was a very negative and antagonistic and
so like the thing is I get those are
other topics for other days but suffice
it to say that I began to read a lot and
as I read I found answers to a lot of
those questions but one insight that
became quite clear to me and a lot of my
study was that in the last few hundred
years
the majority of the American church was
consistently on the wrong side of
history on a number of very key issues
like number one slavery and it's close
cousin racial
nation number two women's rights and
equality and so as I read it became
really clear how powerfully our own
culture influences our reading of the
Bible in other words sometimes people
will say things like well Bible says as
though they're simply reading the text
for it's very clear meaning when
honestly the reality is that they are
not and I do not in you do not I mean
every sermon you've ever heard every
book or article you've ever read every
teacher or mentor you've ever had every
commercial show movie you've ever seen I
mean these they I mean basically your
culture it gives you an eye you might
think of it as like a set of lenses
through which we interpret right we
bring all of that to the text and this
is what makes us for example like when
we read the Bible we might emphasize
certain passages right we might say that
those that's the key those are the key
parts of the Bible while ignoring or
avoiding others or will say things like
now what this used to me you know in
that historical context what it meant
was and then we'll proceed to quote a
scholar often we don't say the scholars
name because we just want a sit off like
it's fact
but we're quoting a scholar who likely
is in conversation with other scholars
and they might disagree and short I
think we could all use not just a bit
but a lot more humility when it comes to
the Bible rather than rat loudly
proclaiming what the Bible says or what
the Bible means and then proceeding to
give our one interpretation as like the
definitive interpretation of the text
and so I as I studied I've noticed this
I've noticed that there are certain
ideas which today we just take as like a
foregone conclusion
that actually
we're hugely controversial
mind-bendingly strange and profoundly
radical just fifty years ago or a
hundred years ago and furthermore I saw
that even certain ideas that we often
assume well of course the Bible condemns
that if you actually read the text you
realize oh no you can actually make a
really strong biblical argument for that
terrible thing like for example and our
not too distant past pastors just like
me would stand up in pulpits and argue
that slavery was a God ordained
institution and I'll probably touch on
that passage in my next episode but the
thing is right that as pastors like that
they have Bible passages and you know
that would seem to agree with them in a
similar way
church leaders make arguments around
women not being you know fit for
leadership for various reasons and again
certain biblical texts seem to make
those arguments and so I was reading I
was studying and I just started to dawn
on me that the reason the church as I
looked back right because hindsight's
20/20 as they say but the reason the
church was consistently on the wrong
side of history was not let me make this
clear
not because they were like uniquely
unintelligent or uniquely terrible
people but because like all of us they
had certain ways of reading the text
handed down to them and they simply took
that as truth and what they weren't
doing was putting that that received
tradition in conversation with new
information by new information I mean
both the information
get from studying write scholarly works
so you can understand the Bible in its
historical context because we often
think it's an easy transition from a
text written 2,000 years ago - you know
21st century America yeah no problem
so that can be one thing I mean by
information but as well as the
information that comes to us by honestly
just talking with people hearing their
stories making sense of them I mean I
suspect if more pastors in the 1800's
had had a different relationship with
people of color might have had a little
more compassion there they might not
been so blinded right so I think that's
also another example of like information
that we need to put in conversation with
the little text file so all that was
happening and I began to ask myself okay
so that's what we've missed in the past
Bret like what are the things or what's
the issue today that your children or
grandchildren are very likely not
guaranteed but are likely to shake their
heads and ask how could you have been so
blind like how could you have let the
culture and your recieved ways of
reading the Bible blind you I mean it's
these are people's stories like did you
not hear their pain how could you do
that and I as I started to think on that
I suspected the thing was going to be
around the affirmation of LGBTQ people
in the church and so I began to read and
study and research to see okay what are
the biblical texts on this topic what
are the historical circumstances
historical circumstances around those
texts what did they mean then how does
that mean you translate to today if at
all how do I make sense of those texts
in light of the stories of my game
lesbian friends and and as well as even
what are the signs
saying on this topic all right what are
psychologists saying on this and again
not that I take any of one of those as
like the truth like I just know what
psychologists are saying that's the
truth or if I you know have gay or
lesbian friend and they tell me a story
well that's the truth it obviously it's
about putting all of those in
conversation and so for me over time as
I did that a pretty clear answer emerged
for me in my mind that I now believe the
majority of the United States church is
making basically the same mistake with
gay lesbian folks that it made with
slavery and women and leadership I as I
see it it's the same song third verse
now sometimes when people hear me say
things like that
their eyes get very big and they're like
a threat like you are a pastor and a man
of God like you have influence don't you
fear leading people astray and to that I
say yes of course that's why even though
at a personal level this has been like
pretty dang costly for me I'm being
straightforward and honest with what I
believe precisely because I think the
church is hurting gay and lesbian folks
and their families and in the long run I
think we're even like I think we're
misrepresenting God's heart I realized
that can sound a bit dramatic but I
really do think this conversation it
matters it can be life and death for
people so is one I take very seriously
so with that in mind
over the next dec 5 or 6 videos or so
I'll be giving just some of my own
thinking and approach on this topic and
to be clear I'm not saying I have some
like knockdown argument that will
convince you all the Bible really does
affirm
lesbian people anymore then I can give
you a knockdown argument that the Bible
condemns slavery or affirms women and
leadership instead I'm simply gonna
offer you reasons that I believe this to
be the case so let's say my heart in
these videos is not I'm not trying to be
antagonistic I'm not saying if you
disagree with me you're homophobic even
if you totally disagree you know what I
love you and I hope you can still help
me and that as brothers and sisters we
can move the conversation forward so
that's all for today if you enjoyed this
video please like it share it comment
below and to ensure you don't miss out
on future episodes you can subscribe to
my youtube channel or my podcasts
anywhere podcasts are offered by
searching bretzel fir'd Tabletalk grace
in peace